لا نعرف ما إذا كان هذا
سيختفي مع ارتفاع درجة حرارة الطقس أم لا
، والسبب في حدوث ذلك هو
أن فيروسات أخرى بما في ذلك
فيروس الأنفلونزا وحتى فيروسات كورونا الأخرى مثل
السارس تميل إلى الوصول إلى هذا النوع من الذروة
في مارس و  أبريل ثم يبدأ في
التقلص حتى تعرف السؤال هل
هذا فيروس كورونا أيضًا هل يمكن أن
يحدث نفس الشيء هنا وقد يحدث
ولكنك تعلم سبب استمرارنا في قول رواية
أمام فيروس كورونا هو أنه
فيروس جديد و  لا نعرف بالضبط
كيف ستتصرف تلك الخريطة
التي عرضتها للتو على خريطة العالم إذا
لاحظت أنك تعرف أن معظم الحالات لا
تزال في نصف الكرة الشمالي حيث
يكون الطقس أكثر برودة ، فقد
بدأت في رؤية بعضها الآن في الأسفل
ولكن ، لكن عددًا أقل من الحالات في
النصف الجنوبي من الكرة الأرضية ، ربما يكون هذا
مؤشرًا على أنه
فيروس طقس أكثر برودة لا نعرفه حتى الآن ،
سيكون هذا هو الأمل
[الموسيقى]
أنت
[الموسيقى
]  هذه هي المدة التي يستغرقها شخص ما  مريض
بالفيروس نسمع تقارير بعدد
من الحالات عدد من الوفيات ولكن بالنسبة
لأولئك الذين لا يموتون كم من الوقت
يمرضون سؤال مهم وهو يعتمد
على شدة المرض ولكن
دعني أقول هذا بسرعة أنك
تعرف مع الأشخاص الذين عانوا من أمراض أكثر خطورة
وتعافوا من أن فترة التعافي
قد تصل إلى ستة أسابيع ، لذلك علينا أن نضع
ذلك في الاعتبار خاصة عندما يتعلق الأمر
بالاستشفاء والرعاية الطبية ،
فليس من المعروف أنه ليس نوعًا سريعًا من
الذروة  قد يستغرق مقدار الرعاية التي
قد يحتاجها المرضى وقتًا طويلاً ،
حسنًا ، لذا هل أنت معدي يجب أن
تكون في الحجر الصحي في جميع الأوقات حتى تتمكن من البقاء على
قيد الحياة طالما
أنك لا تزال تعاني من الأعراض ، فلا يزال من الممكن أن
تكون معديًا.  التخلص
من الفيروس لذلك يحتاج الناس في كثير من الأحيان
إلى عزلهم خلال تلك الفترة ،
حسنًا ، هذا من Facebook ،
يوضح لماذا يستغرق 14 فترة حضانة لمدة 14 يومًا
وهل نعرف متى
يصبح معديًا خلال تلك الفترة ، نعم
لذلك يبدأ الفيروس في الدخول إلى جسمك في
التكاثر ، ولكن قد يستغرق الأمر بعض الوقت في
هذه الحالة حتى 14 يومًا من فترة الحضانة
قبل أن يبدأ شخص ما في
ظهور الأعراض التي
يتكاثر بها الفيروس ولكنك لا
تشعر به حقًا ويمكنه التكاثر من أجل ذلك
فترة من الوقت قبل
ظهور الأعراض على شخص ما لمدة 14 يومًا ، يمكن أن تكون معديًا على
الفور حتى قبل ظهور الأعراض ،
وهذا جزء من القلق الذي يحتمل أن
يكون الفيروس في جسمك لفترة وجيزة
واضطررت إلى الانقسام بما يكفي
لبدء الدخول فعليًا إلى تجويف الأنف الخاص بك
حيث  تبدأ في التخلص من الفيروس ولكن
أعتقد أن النقطة الأكثر بروزًا هي أنه حتى
بدون أعراض قد تكون معديًا
وليس من المحتمل أن تكون معديًا
وفقًا للطبيب السيء تشي كشخص
مريض بشكل واضح يسعل ويعطس ولكن
من الممكن أن تنتشر الفيروس
دون أن تعرف نفسك
حسنًا ، الأشخاص الأكثر تضررًا من
فيروس كورونا هم كبار السن والأشخاص الذين
يعانون من ظروف كامنة ، فلماذا يوجد
الكثير من المدارس  ختامًا ، حسنًا ، أولاً وقبل
كل شيء ، يميل الشباب إلى الحماية إلى حد ما
من هذا الفيروس ، لسنا
متأكدين تمامًا من سبب
إصابتهم بالفيروس ،
لكنهم لا يصابون بالفعل
بمرض خطير ولكن سبب
إغلاقهم  المدارس وهذا ما تعرفه ، أحد
هذه الأسئلة التي تعرفها الولايات المتحدة التي
تعلمون أنه سيتعين علينا التعامل معها
هو حقًا لأنه لا يزال من الممكن أن
يكون الفيروس في نظامك ، يمكنك العودة إلى
المنزل ، ويمكنك نشره إلى الآباء
والأجداد الذين يمكن أن تصبح نوعًا ما  من
نواقل الفيروس والمدارس
خاصة للأطفال الصغار تميل إلى أن تكون
هذه الأماكن التي تنتشر فيها الفيروسات بسهولة ،
لذلك يمكن للكثير من الأطفال ، على الرغم من أنهم قد لا
يكونون مرضى ، أن يعودوا إلى منازلهم
ويبدأوا في الانتشار على الأشخاص الذين قد يكونون أكثر
عرضة للإصابة.
قائمة
بالأشياء المعتمدة رسميًا من وكالة حماية البيئة (EPA) والتي هي
مطهرات قد تكون قوية بما
يكفي لقتل فيروس كورونا وإليك
ما نتحدث عنه وهو القائمة
التي تذهب إليها أكثر من غيرها.  y Clorox وغالبًا
Lysol ، لذا فهي ليست أشياء مناسبة
ليديك كما ترى منظفات المرحاض
هنا ولكن هذه هي الأشياء التي يقولون أنه
يمكنك استخدامها هناك ، أعتقد أن هذا
ليس أقل مما يمكنك استخدامه
بدلاً من الدفع للشركات الأخرى  لا يمكنك
التظاهر بأنك قادر على محاربة فيروس كورونا ،
لقد كانت رحلة تقاعد
خططنا لها في اليوم التالي
لعيد الشكر ، وصلنا إلى اليابان في
الرابع من مارس ، وذلك عندما
نأسف للحجر الصحي بعد أربعة أيام من
الحجر الصحي  وبدأت أصاب بالمرض
في البداية ، كان الأمر صعبًا ، كانت
حمى إليزابيت وصداعًا سيئًا ، ولكن
بعد ذلك اليوم الأول ، كان
الناس يأتون ويذهبون ويذهبون ، وقد فعلوا
ذلك لمدة أربعة أيام عندما
ذهب الغثيان  استيقظت في الصباح
وكان ذلك جيدًا ، لقد كان الأمر مروعًا لأنه
بعد مغادرته أعني أننا قبلنا الوداع
واحتضننا وأنت تعلم أنك لا تعرف ،
ثم اتصلت بمكتب الاستقبال وقلت
مرحبًا كيف يمكنني معرفة مكان
ذهاب الزوج و  قالت حسنًا إننا لا نعرف
[موسيقى]
لقد استلقيت للتو على سرير المستشفى هناك
في الغرفة ، ووضعت رأسي على الوسادة
الملتفة في أصلع صغير ، لقد كان الأمر
مخيفًا بعض الشيء بالنسبة لي والآن
أنا وحدي  كنت أعلم أنه سيكون وقتًا طويلاً لقد
فقدت 25 رطلاً ، فقد 20 منها حصلت على حبوب منع الحمل
لا أوصي بالنظام الغذائي اليوم هو
اليوم الثاني الذي أكون فيه هنا
وتحدثت إلى جون ، لقد كان الأمر فظيعًا بالنسبة لنا ،
نعم يا روح معًا
حسنًا 84 7 وعندما غادرت ظننت
أنك تعلم أنه كان من المفترض أن نغادر
معًا ، قاموا بفحصي كل يومين
بحثًا عن فيروس النهر ، ثم
عاد دائمًا إيجابيًا في يوم من الأيام فقط
عندما جاء الطبيب وخلع قفازته
وهو  يقول يصافح يدي
بجلده العاري ويقول إن الاختبار سلبي ،
أنت ذاهب إلى المنزل بشكل جيد عزيزتي ،
اليوم السعيد هنا ، أنا حر في الذهاب ولا
أطيق الانتظار لأضع ذراعي من حولك ، سأعود إلى
المنزل ، لقد كان الأول  الوقت الذي كنت
أعانق فيه أي شخص خلال ما يزيد قليلاً عن
أسبوعين وسأضطر إلى معانقة زوجتي مرة أخرى
[موسيقى]
نعم الابتهاج فقط من أجل  أراه وأنت
تعلم أنه يقدم أفضل العناق على أي حال ، لذا
بعد الانتهاء من ذلك ، نريد نوعًا ما
أن نتخلص من الوزن كما تعلم أننا نحب أن
نكون زوجين عاديين يعيشان
حياة غير عادية
[موسيقى]